región dijo raúl que este invierno será
bastante gris que eeuu vivirá una de las
crisis de salud pública más grande en su
historia dijo además que además de estos
200.000 casos que se reportan al día en
febrero estos casos podrían llegar a los
450 mil casos diarios y es que raúl
además de los 2 mil 800 muertes que se
registran al día y las 200.000 casos de
kobe también registrados al día también
hay 100 mil estadounidenses que han
ingresado ayer lo hicieron a los
hospitales a las unidades de cuidado
intensivo esto ha hecho que estados como
california decreten un 'toque de queda'
le digan a sus ciudadanos que se queden
en casa sobre todo en áreas donde los
hospitales pues ya llegan a el tope de
unidades de cuidados intensivos además
facebook facebook también dijo que
quitará de su página toda esa
información con respecto al comité
cristóbal y es que para hacer frente a
esta crisis sanitaria y sus efectos
económicos el congreso estaba debatiendo
un paquete de ayuda de cerca de un
billón de dólares le pregunto si se
logrará aprobar este paquete antes de
fin de este año
este paquete era de 14 billones de
dólares pero ahora será de 908 mil
millones de dólares los demócratas
bajaron este monto para poder que la
mayoría republicana en el senado y el
presidente trump puedan firmar esta ley
de paquete de ayuda lo que no quieren
los republicanos es que estos fondos
vayan a parar a los estados y con estos
fondos se pague un subsidio a los
desempleados pero ya nancy pelosi que es
la presidenta demócrata de la cámara de
representantes y el presidente del
senado mitch mcconnell hablaron hoy y
precisamente después de esta reunión
michoacano dijo que ve muy cerca un
acuerdo
donald trump también fue cuestionado hoy
al respecto y dijo que también ve muy
cerca un acuerdo el último acuerdo
paquete de ayuda que se firmó fue en
marzo este paquete fue de 2,2 billones
de dólares que es total gracias por la
información era nuestro corresponsal en
washington dice cristóbal vázquez y
tengo usted una muy buena noche